[Music]
are all viruses the same let us step
back for a bit what is a virus a virus
is an extremely small infectious agent
it infects all type of life-forms from
animals to plants and even other
microbes like bacteria on their own they
do not have the ability to replicate and
can only replicate inside living cells
of an organism for this they rely on the
complex machinery of the host cell to
top it off they often cause a disease in
their host organism which facilitates
the replication process have you watched
the video about the similarity between a
corona virus and a thief that video will
give you a basic background knowledge
about viruses so back to a main question
are all viruses the same no they're not
there are different types of viruses
they are different in size shape and the
kinds of cells they attack each type of
virus would look for a particular type
of cell to attack think about the jigsaw
puzzles are you able to fit any piece
anywhere of course not the specific
unique shape of each piece will allow it
to fit in one particular spot only
similarly viruses are of unique types
each unique type of virus attacks a
particular type of cell for example HIV
infects the t-cells
destroying a human beings immune system
Fars one infects lung cells causing
severe respiratory problems the novel
coronavirus initially attacks the throat
cells how did the viruses choose which
type of cell to attack
remember the analogy about a thief
looking for a house which he could gain
access to with his key it's very similar
the coronavirus has a spike protein
which attaches to a cell which has the
protein is to the spike protein works
like a key to open the door to the cell
it fits in perfectly like a jigsaw piece
so the HIV cannot attach to a cell with
the yeast to protein it will only fit
correctly with a t cell once attached it
initiates the process which eventually
leads to infiltrating the cell the virus
then uses the protein making capability
of the cell and replicates itself
rapidly the host cell is eventually
destroyed the replicated viruses will
look for similar cells and attach
themselves accelerating the organ
destruction process I hope you've
learned something from this video and if
you think it will be useful to someone
else please do share it with them
this brings me to a question how do we
stay safe from viruses what's the best
way to defend ourselves we look at that
next till then stay safe
[Music]